♪ ♪
>> Trace: WELL, TESTING HAS
BECOME A PRIORITY DOWN FOR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BOOK FOR
THE HEALTH CARE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE WITH THE NEED FOR TESTING
KIDS COMES THE RISE IN FAKE KIDS
FROM THOSE LOOKING TO PROFIT ON
FEAR.
U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION SEIZING A SHIPMENT OF
FAKE COVID-19 THE LOS ANGELES
AIRPORT TWO WEEKS AGO AND THEN
CHICAGO’S O’HARE AIRPORT LAST
WEEK AND ALL DO TO BE PURCHASED
BY DESPERATE AMERICANS WONDERING
IF THEY HAVE THE CORONAVIRUS.
ADDING THE POSITIVE POSSIBILITY
OF THE FALSE TON OF STUFF IT’S
GOOD TO KNOW WHAT THE TRUE
TESTING IS.
HARVARD MEDICAL SCHOOL
GRADUATES, DOCTOR, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AND WE LOOK AT THE
REPORTS OF BOGUS TESTS AND HOW
DO YOU KNOW THESE THINGS ARE
LEGIT?
>> RIGHT, FIRST QUESTION ALWAYS
IS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON
TONIGHT AND WE STAND TOGETHER AS
A NATION FACING THE HORRIBLE
PANDEMIC.
THE FIRST QUESTION ALWAYS IS IF
SOMETHING SEEMS TO BE GOOD TO BE
TRUE, IT PROBABLY IS.
SO AT HEART, EVERYTHING’S PRETTY
MUCH STRAIGHTFORWARD SO IF NO
ONE IN THE COUNTRY CAN REALLY
GET ADEQUATE TESTING AND WE ARE
SO BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL IN
TERMS OF ADEQUATE TESTING AND
MOST OF OUR CITIZENS AND YOU GET
A KIT IN THE MAIL FOR 250 OR
$300, AND TEN OR 15 MINUTES WITH
A TREMENDOUS ACCURACY, YOU KNOW
IT’S NOT REALLY THE CASE RIGHT
NOW.
>> Trace: THAT’S THE WHOLE
THING, YOU SEE SOME OF THE
TESTS, DOCTOR I HAD TO INTERRUPT
YOU BUT A LITTLE BIT OF A DELAY
ON SKYPE YOU SEE SOME OF THE
TESTS OUT THERE AND YOU’RE
HEARING ABOUT THESE AND OH,
YEAH, PUT IT ON THE THING AND
THEN YOU GOT IT AND HOW DO WE
KNOW?
I MEAN, PHYSICALLY HOW DO YOU
KNOW THAT YOU’RE DOING THE TEST
PROPERLY?
>> SO FROM START TO FINISH YOU
WANT TO SEE IF IT HAS THE RIGHT
TYPE OF SWAB AND THIS IS THE
UNIVERSAL YOU TM SWAB.
IT’S A DIACHRONIC OR A PLASTIC
SWAB AND NOT THE KIND OF SWAB
TEST WHEAT USE FOR NORMAL
BACTERIAL CULTURES IN THE OFFICE
WHERE WE OFTENTIMES CHECK FOR
STREP THROAT DO IT THESE ARE THE
PLASTIC ONES AND UNFORTUNATELY,
THEY’RE MANUFACTURED MOSTLY IN
ITALY WHICH IS WHY THERE’S ALSO
A KIND OF NATIONWIDE OR REGIONAL
SHORTAGE IN THE NORTHERN
HEMISPHERE FOR THE SWABS.
WHEN THE DOCTOR CHECKS OUT, IF
THEY ARE DOING IT AND THEY’RE
VERY EXPERIENCED WITH IT, THEY
WILL BE CHECKING NOT JUST THE
FRONT OF YOUR NOSE, THEY WILL BE
GOING FROM THE FRONT OF THE NOSE
AND WHAT I TELL MY PATIENTS,
IT’S GOING TO BE THE MOST
UNPLEASANT KNOW SWAB I’VE EVER
DONE ON YOUR PARADE WE GO FROM
THE FRONT OF THE NOSE WHERE IS
THERE SOME PRETTY GOOD
CONCENTRATION ON VIRUS PARTICLES
TO THE VERY BACK ABOUT THREE AND
A HALF INCHES IN.
SO BASICALLY, THE NOSE MEETS THE
THROAT AND IT FEELS LIKE I’M
ALMOST ON YOUR TONSILS THROUGH
YOUR NOSE.
THAT’S THE HIGHEST CONCENTRATION
OF VIRUS FOR ALMOST EVERY
RESPIRATORY VIRUS WHETHER THAT
BE THE FLU, INFLUENZA, AND
STUDIES FROM THE CDC SHOW THAT
THE TEST THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
OFFICE IF WE SWAB THE FRONT OF
THE NOSE, THEY WILL PICK UP IF
FOUR PEOPLE AND A ROOM WITH
INFLUENZA, THEY WILL PICK UP AT
BEST THREE.
BECAUSE YOU’RE STILL GOING TO
MISS WHAT’S CALLED SAMPLING
ERROR AND THAT’S LIKE GOING INTO
A SCHOOL AND SEEING THE FIRST OF
TEST THE FIRST CLASSROOM PROCESS
TO THE DOOR.
IF YOU NOT GOING TO GET THE MOST
ACCURATE SAMPLE OF HOW MANY
CLASSROOMS ARE FULL.
IF SAME WITH YOUR NOSE.
IF YOU CHECKING IN THE MOUTH OR
BUCCAL MUCOSA, IT’S REDUCED
COMPARED TO THAT IN THE NOSE.
THAT’S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, WHAT KIND OF TEST AS
IT GOES AND MOST PHYSICIANS, I’M
A SURGEON SO WE DO A LOT OF
TESTS THAT ARE SPECIFIC AND
NECESSARY, SO WHEN WE CHECK IN,
WERE CHECKING THE GOLD STANDARD
OF THE GOLD STANDARD THE
ROLLS-ROYCE OF MOST OF THE KIND
OF TESTS IS CALLED ECR.
GLAMOROUS CHAIN REACTION AND IS
USED IN CRIME SCENE
INVESTIGATIONS LIKE WE SEE 50
COPIES OF ANY VIRUS, ANYONE’S
BLOOD SAMPLE AND AMPLIFY THAT
WITH THE PCR THE CHAIN REACTION
AND FIND THE CHAIN REACTION AND
70sDNA.
IF THAT’S THE NEWEST OF PCR, AND
BY DIAGNOSTICS ARE THE LARGEST
LAB IN THE COUNTRY AND THEN THE
HANDFUL OF REALLY OTHER SOLID
PLATFORMS THAT DICKINSON HAS
ONE, BY A FIRE, THE NEWEST ONE
THAT GOT APPROVAL, CDP H I.D.
>> Trace: THEY DON’T MEAN A
LOT OF PEOPLE THEY’RE NOT
WRITING THEM DOWN, BUT DR. WILL
MAKE IT YOUR OPINION IF I CAN
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE
DR. DEBORAH BIRX IS TALKING
ABOUT TESTING BOTH DIAGNOSTICS
AND SURVEILLANCE AND PLAY HER
SOUND BITE AND GET YOUR RESPONSE
ON THE GMAC OTHER SIDE.
>> IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
TESTING, IT TELLS YOU IF YOU’RE
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE THAT DAY
AND YOU COULD BECOME POSITIVE
THE NEXT TODAY.
SO TESTING SHOULD BE USED
POTENTIALLY AS A SURVEILLANCE
TOOL OR DIAGNOSTIC TOOL.
I THINK WHAT WE’RE GOING TO WORK
ON OVER THE WEEKEND IS SO THAT
WE TOOK OTHER BOTH A TESTING
STRATEGY FOR SURVEILLANCE, WHICH
YOU HAVE BROUGHT UP IN THAT KEY
POINTS, WHILE MAINTAINING A
STRONG TESTING FOR DIAGNOSIS.
OUR FIRST OBLIGATION INSTALLED
TO ENSURE THAT PATIENTS GET
DIAGNOSED.
>> Trace: TESTING FOR
SURVEILLANCE AND DIAGNOSTIC AND
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO YOU AS AN
EMT?
>> WRITES, SO, IF SOMEONE’S BEEN
EXPOSED TO CORONAVIRUS AND LET’S
SAY YOUR DAUGHTER HAS IT, YOUR
NEIGHBOR HAS IT, YOUR MOTHER HAS
IT AND MOST PEOPLE WILL MANIFEST
LIKENING EXPOSED TO THE FLU
BETWEEN THE FOURTH OR FIFTH DAY
AND ABOUT THE TENTH DAY.
ALL THE WAY OUT TO 14 DAYS BUT
95% OF PEOPLE, WITHIN THE
BELL CURVE WHERE THE FOURTH
DATED THE TENTH DAY WE WILL SEE
THAT THEY’RE GOING TO TURN UP
POSITIVE AND HAVE SYMPTOMS.
WITHIN A DAY OR TWO OF SYMPTOMS,
ALMOST EVERYONE HAS THE HIGHEST
YIELD FOR THAT KIND OF TEST.
THEY PCR ANOTHER TYPE OF TEST
THAT’S WHEN YOU’RE GOING TO GET
YOUR MONEY’S WORTH IT SO TO
SPEAK.
THAT’S THE DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
AND OTHERWISE IF YOU TEST IN THE
FIRST THREE OR SO DAYS IT’S
GOING TO BE NEGATIVE AND THEN
OUT LATER, YOU’RE GOING TO PICK
UP ANOTHER SMALLER PORTION OF
PEOPLE IN THE SWEET SPOTS, THE
MIDDLE 8-10 DAYS WHERE YOU FIND
IT DIAGNOSTIC.
>> Trace: DOCTOR, I’VE GOT TO
GO BY THEM AND ASK YOU VERY
QUICKLY, ARE WE GETTING FASTER
AT THE TEST RESULTS?
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE WE’RE
GETTING BETTER AT THIS STUFF.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, WITH THE GOLD
STANDARD TEST LIKE THE PCR, IT
STILL TAKES A SOLID DAY OR TWO.
THE NEW MACHINES THAT ARE
AUTOMATED CAN DO A RESULT WITHIN
A DAY BUT THE TRULY FAST ONES
CAN DO A TURNAROUND WITHIN THE
HOUR.
IT STILL TRANSPORTING THE TESTS
FROM THE PERSON TO THE
LABORATORY AND THEN GETTING IT
IN THE QUEUE TO RUN IT AND THEN
EACH MACHINE CAN ONLY RUN SO
MANY PER HOUR.
SO IT’S GOING TO TAKE AT LEAST
ONE DAY AND ALMOST ALL PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY.
>> Trace: AT WOW, DOCTOR,